وهذه اخبار الساعه
يورانيوم مستنفذ الى كياب واخر حقيقي الى
بيلاروسيا يقربان خطوات من الحرب النوويه
مساعي الولايات المتحده لحظر تيك توك
تقابل بزياده شعبيه التطبيق واشنطن
تتنافسان على الخوارزميات
[موسيقى]
المحتجون في فرنسا يستبقون الخميس الاسود
بالتظاهر وماكرون يتحداهم ويصر على قانون
التقاعد
بعد اسبوعين داميين في القطاع المصرفي
الفيدرالي الامريكي يرفع الفائده بمعدل
ربع نقطه مئويه
[موسيقى]
اوقاتا كل عام وانتم بخير نبدا اخبار
الساعه من اليورانيوم المستنفذ حرب نوويه
قريبه لحوف الافق حيث اثار اعلانوا
بريطانيا عن خطه لارسال ذخيره تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المستنفذ لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا اثار غضب روسيا الرئيس روسيا
فلاديمير بوتين هدد بالرد وقال ان روسيا
ستكون مضطره للرد في حال تزويد اوكرانيا
بهذه القذائف فيما حذر وزير الدفاع الروسي
من انصدام نووي محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل
متبقيه قبل حدوث صدام نووي محتمل بين
روسيا والغرب بدوره اكد وزير الخارجيه
ان تمت ستصعد الموقف الى مستويات جديده
وخطيره وستؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه على علاقات
البلدين
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكر نتائج استخدام
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في يوغسلافيا
والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات الالاف من
المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين استخدموا
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك
وفي مقابل الحديث عن تزويد كييف
باليورانيوم مستنفذ موسكو هي الاخرى تتجه
لتزويد الجاره بيلاروسيا بيورانيوم لكن
هذه المره يورانيوم حقيقي
اذا كان الناس في الدول الغربيه مجانين
فانهم يعطون زخما لهذه العمليه هذا هو
الشيء الاكثر فظاعه والاكثر خطوره ولهذا
السبب من الضروري الابتعاد قليلا عن
الجنون بمجرد ان تنفجر هذه الذخيره في
مواقع القوه الروسيه سيكون الرد درسا
رهيبا لكوكب الارض باكمله انها ليست فكره
جيده لبدء توجه نحو التصعيد في هذه الحرب
نحتاج للتحرك نحو حل سلمي مثلما تحدث
الرئيسان الروسي والصيني
وفي اخر تطورات هذا اليورانيوم المستنفذ
الان البيت الابيض في هذا التصريح قذائف
اليورانيوم المستنفذ او المنظم هي المرسله
الى اوكرانيا لا تشكل تهديدا بانتشار
اشعاعي في هذه الاثناء
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض اذن تتحدث عن
الموضوع اذا وهو موضوعنا الرئيس في اخبار
الساعه لهذه الليله
واردا على تصريحات الروسيه دفع المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عن الامر
مؤكدا ان الجيش البريطاني استخدم
اليورانيوم المستنفذ في قذائفه خارقه
للدروع لعقود كما اوضح وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه ان تزويد كييف اليورانيوم
المستنفذ ليس تصعيد النوويا متهما بانها
هي من تسعى لذلك
[موسيقى]
شبح تطور الصراع في اوكرانيا لحرب النوويه
عاد للواجهه من جديد موسكو توعدت لندن
بنهايه سيئه اذا نفذت تعهد بارسال قذائف
مصنوعه من اليورانيوم المخضب الى كييف
التعهد البريطاني جلب ردود افعال الروسيه
لو تحققت فربما تنقل الصراع في اوكرانيا
الى مرحله مخيفه الرئيس الروسي حذر من ان
بلاده ستضطر الى الرد وتعمل غرب بنشر
اسلحه تحمل مكونا نوويا التحذير الروسي
شمل واشنطن رغم نفي البنتاجون اي دور
لبلاده في هذا الشان فخرجت
واضح ان الغرب قرر محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا ليس فقط بالكلام بل بالافعال اذا
حصل هذا الشيء فستجد روسيا نفسها مجبره
على الرد بما يتناسب مع تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا باسلحه نوويه
بريطانيا من جهتها بدات غير قلقه من سيل
الوعيد الروسي بل علقت بسخريه على ما صدر
عن الكرملين ووصفته بالتضليل المقصود
واقرت الدفاع البريطانيه ان جيشها يستخدم
اليورانيوم المخطب في قبائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود هذه النوعيه من القذائف
خطيره على البيئه حيث قالت الامم المتحده
انها قد تشكل مصدر قلق بيئي في اوكرانيا
لما قد تسببه من امراض بما في ذلك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان حنان المصري العربيه
اذا نتابع قضيه قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
او المستنفذ مع مراسلتي العربيه من موسكو
ولندن وعروب عبد الحق مرحبا بكما عروب
ابداء معك اخر التصريحات والمواقف
البريطانيه حول استعداد لندن للتسليم
قذائف اليورانيوم والمستفد الى اوكرانيا
مرحبا صهيب يعني موقف بريطانيا واضح كما
في التقرير هي قللت من شان الاتهامات
الروسيه قالت بان اليورانيوم المستنفذ
الذي يستخدم في الذخيره يستخدم منذ عقود
وبالتالي يعني هي قللت من شان هذه
الاتهامات قالت وزاره الدفاع في بيان لها
بان المعلومات او الاتهامات الروسيه ما هي
الا نشر معلومات مضلله
اليورانيوم المستنفذ المستخدم في الذخيره
يستخدم منذ عقود والجيش البريطاني يستخدمه
كمكون عادي في الذخيره وهو يعني سلاح
تقليدي ايضا وزير الخارجيه كما ذكرت جيمس
كليبر الذي كان له تصريحات قال بان روسيا
هي من تصاعد او هي المتخوفه من تصعيد نووي
ولا حديث هناك عن تصعيد نووي وانما يعني
المساعده او التي تقدمها بريطانيا فيما
يخص الذخيره التي تستخدم اليوراني هي يتم
يعني يتم ارسالها في الموقف الواضح من
بريطانيا بانها تساعد اوكرانيا في هذه
الحرب كما كان هناك ايضا تصريح لقائد في
القائد سابق في الجيش ايضا قال انه من
المضحك ان ان روسيا تعتقد بان هذه الذخيره
لها قدرات نوويه
وروسيا يعني تستعد ربما للرد على هذه
الخطوه بارسال يورانيوم حقيقي الى
بيلاروسيا كاتيا اسالك كذلك
عطفا على ما قالهم قال ان نهايه العالم
النوويه باتت قريبه المزيد من التصريحات
الروسيه حول اليورانيوم المستنفذ
بالفعل صهيب التصريحات الروسيه لم منذ
الصباح ومنذ يوم امس ايضا للرد على الخطوه
التي ستتخذها لندن كما قالت متحدثه
الرسميه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه مريضه قالت
ان هذا استخدام هذه الخزائف هو مظهر من
مظاهر الاباده الجماعيه التي ستؤثر على
صحه المواطنين الاوكرانيين
والعقود اما بالنسبه لرئيس مجلس الدمى قال
ان اوروبا او الغرب يحارب ليس حتى اخر
اوكرانيا بل حتى اخر اوروبي كما تحدث لان
هذا استخدام هذا مثل هذه الخزائح سيؤثر
على الاوروبيين ايضا طبعا هو هي خطوه
تصعديه تعتبرها موسكو كانت قد تحدث اليوم
ان هي خطوه جديده في التصعيد الرئيس
الروسي اكد انه سيكون هناك طبعا بالرد في
حال استخدام هذه
القذائفو كان قد قال ان العالم اصبح اقرب
بخطوه ليحدث هناك مواجهه نوويه طيب عروب
اعود اليك
هل هناك علم بموعد تسليم لندن لهذه
الصواريخ صواريخ اليورانيوم المستنفذ الى
اوكرانيا
وهل في ضوء هذا الغضب الروسي والتهديد
الروسي يمكن ان تتراجع بريطانيا عن هذه
الخطوه
يعني صهيب لا يبدو ان هناك اي تصريحات
تشير الى ان هناك تراجع من بريطانيا في
ارسال هذه الذخائر ونحن نعلم ان ارسال هذه
الذخائر ياتي يعني
كما نعلم ان بريطانيا ترسل دبابات من نوع
تشالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا هذه الذخائر هي
خاصه بهذه الدبابات ونحن نعلم بان الموعد
الذي اعطاه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني لتسليم
هذه الدبابات هو في نهايه هذا الشهر ولكن
لا موعد واضح حتى الان اذا ما كانت ستسلم
في الموعد الذي حدده رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني
اذا لم يتراجع البريطانيون عن الخطوه ماذا
ستفعل موسكو
يعني قررت مرارا ان الغرب تزويدها الاسلحه
هو طرف في النزاع وبالتالي هذه الخطوه هي
تصعيديه كما تحدث جميع المسؤولين في موسكو
هي خطوه نحو التصعيد وبالتالي في حاله
استخدام هذه الاسلحه سيكون هناك رد روسي
طبعا روسيا كانت قد تحدثت ايضا انها
ملتزمه بمعاهده انتشار عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه كما تحدث اليوم ايضا لابروف ان
روسيا هي ملتزمه بالعقيده النوويه لذلك
هذه الخطوه في حال تم ارسال هذه الاسلحه
ستكون هي تاكيد خطوه لا يحمد عقباها كما
تحدث بعض الخبراء كاتيا طعمه وعروب عبد
الحق مراسله العربيه من موسكو ولندن شكرا
جزيلا لكما
وكما ذكرنا قبل قليلة الدفاع البريطانيه
ان الجيش استخدم اليورانيوم المستنفذ منذ
عقود حدث ذلك من قبل واشنطن خلال حرب
العراق في 2003 وتحدث عن ذلك ماذا عن
نتائج ومخاطر هذا الاستخدام منتظر رشيد
والتفاصيل
استخدمت القوات الامريكيه خلال غزوها
العراق قبل عشرين عاما قذائف اليوران يوم
المنظف بكميات كبيره في جنوب البلاد وفي
معركه بغداد الشهيره هذا الامر تسبب
بانتشار امراض السرطان بكثره كما انه تسبب
بتشوهات خلقيه وما يزال لاعداد كبيره من
المواليد الجدد هذا المستشفى وغيره يكافحه
لعلاج مرضى السرطان لكنه غير قادر على ذلك
لارتفاع التكاليف وعدم توفر الادويه
اللازمه
[موسيقى]
اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السياسي والمادي لروسيا يتعرض مع مصالح
واشنطن او يتعارض مع مصالحها مضيفنا نصين
لم تتجاوز بعد الخط الاحمر لتسليم موسكو
اسلحه الفتاكه وقال ان رد فعل الغرب على
الهجوم الروسيه في اوكرانيا يجب ان يكون
بمثابه الدرس للصين
على سبيل المثال الكل يراقب استجابتنا
لهذا العدوان وهو ما يجعلهم يستجيبون لهذه
الدروس انضم حلفاؤنا من اسيا بالرغم من ان
الحرب تقع على النصف الاخر من العالم
بالنسبه لهم وهذا بسبب احساسهم بالخطر
ايضا اليابان احدى الدول الرائده في
تحالفنا الداعم لاوكرانيا كما تلعب كوريا
الجنوبيه دورا هاما ايضا نفس الشيء
بالنسبه لاستراليا اذا نظرات الصين لما
يحدث بعنايه شديده فسوف تستخلص الدروس حول
قدره العالم على الوحده امام عدوان مماثل
للصين مصلحه استراتيجيه في انتصار بوتين
تريد تقديم الدعم لروسيا لكن في نفس الوقت
لا تريد المخاطره بالعقوبات الغربيه على
اقتصادها وهي التي لتوها فتحت حدودها منذ
سنوات من الاغلاق بسبب كورونا هذا ما
ناقشه بوتينغ خلال زياره الاخير لموسكو
بحسب تقرير لشبكه سي ان بي سي لكن لا شيء
ياتي بالمجال او حسب المثل الصيني لا عشاء
مجانيا ليكون السؤال ماذا ستستفيد الصين
من روسيا في المقابل الامر الاول هو ان
روسيا باتت مصدر رخيصا للغايه للطاقه الى
الصين وهنا اشارت الشبكه الى عرض بوت
للصفقات السلع طويله الامد باسعار مخفضه
للصين الامر
ظهر في تصريح بوتين يوم امس بامكاننا
امداد الصين بكامل احتياجاتها من الطقس
الامر الثاني الذي تتطلع له الصين وهو
الحصول على دعم من روسيا اذا دخلت في نزاع
مسلح مع تايوان والتوترات واشنطن بشان ش
به الجزيره يزداد كل يوم عن سابقه وهناك
زياره لرئيسه تايوان نهايه الشهر للولايات
المتحده الامر الثالث هو تمتع روسيا
بميزات كبيره على مستوى صناعه العسكريه
والتقنيات النوويه يمكن للبكين ان تستفيد
منها
زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا فتحت الباب
امام التفسيرات والتاويلات بخصوص الهدف
منها وما ترمي اليه في جبه وسيط لحل
الصراع في اوكرانيا وحاملا خطه للسلام
هكذا حاول تقديم نفسه وهو يعلم ما يدور في
مخيلات بوتين الزعيم الصيني راى في
الزياره فرصه للرد على الولايات المتحده
ودعم صورته كرجل دوله عالمي في حين كان
بوتين يحاول تقديم نفسه بانه يحظى بدعم
احد اقوى قاده العالم حتى في الوقت الذي
تعمل فيه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على
عزله الرئيس الصيني اصطف بقوه مع روسيا ضد
الولايات المتحده لكنهم تنعى عن تقديم شيء
كان يبحث عنه بوتين الا وهو الالتزام
بشراء المزيد من الغاز فالصين تسعى لتجنب
مواجهه عقوبه اقتصاديه غربيه اكثر صرامه
يمكن ان تلحق الضرر بالاقتصاد الصيني
وحين كان شيجيبينغ يجري مبحثات مع
المسؤولين الروس في مادبه عشاء فاخره
بموسكو كان رئيس الوزراء الياباني على بعد
800 كيلومتر يضع اكليلا من الورود في بلده
بوتشا على ارواح القتل الاوكرانيين في
الحرب
فكياف تحظى بتعاطف ودعم كبير من طوكيو
القلقه مما يمكن ان يحدث لها اذا ما اقدمت
الصين على غزو تايوان هي احداث تسير في خط
متوازن غير ان زيارتي الزعيمين الاسيويين
بما لها من رمزيه لم تحدث اي فرق في ميدان
المعركه حتى الان الذي تستعير ناره ولا
تتوقف مدافعه عن القصف بلال البجدين
العربيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
انتهى الثلاثاء وجاء الاربعاء وانتهى ولم
يعتقل ترامبا المدعي العام في منهاتن اجل
توجيه الاتهام لتقديم ادله اضافيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افاده شبكه سي ان ان
المدعي العام في منهاتن اجل توجيه الاتهام
للترامب اليوم من اجل تقديم ادله اضافيه
في الاثناء اكد مصدر لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
ان تاجيل جاء وذلك لسماع الادله بخصوص
قضيه احتمال دفع ترامب 130 الف دولار
للممثله ستورمي دانيلز واسمها الحقيقي
قبل اسبوعين من انتخابات رئاسه عام 2016
بهدف منعها من الكشف عن علاقه حميمه
جمعتها بترامب خارج اطار الزواج
هذا وكتب الرئيس الامريكي السابق منشورا
يشير الى انه قد لا يواجه لائحه اتهام في
النهائي وذلك في تحقيق المدعي العام في
منهاتن بخصوص دفع اموال للممثله الاباحيه
ونشر ترامب على منصه صوره لمقال يشير الى
ان المصادر تقول ان هناك فرصه حقيقيه لمنع
المدعي العام في منهات من توجيه الاتهام
الى ترامب ومع ذلك اوضح متحدث باسم ترامب
ان الرئيس السابق لم يتم اختاره رسميا بعد
بتهم المواجهه اليه وكان يستند في مزاعمه
الى تقارير اعلاميه
معنى مباشره من امام محكمه الجنايات في
منهات جنوب نيويورك مراسل العربيه حسين
اخر تفاصيل فيما يتعلق بهذه التهم التي
تلاحق دونالد ترامب وموقفه كذلك في هذه
القضيه
بقضيه جنائيه لانه يمكن ان يكون هناك
تاثير بالفعل على مشروع ترشحه للانتخابات
في 2024
جنحه او غير جنحه هذا الامر لن يؤثر على
موضوع ترشحه هو بحسب الدستور الامريكي
يستطيع ان يترشح حتى ولو كان في السجن هذا
ما اخبرنا
ذلك
نعم اسمعك بوضوح حسين تفضل واصل
[موسيقى]
قانون يمكنه ان يترشحوا في السجن فذلك لن
يؤثر عليه الموضوع حسب ما يقول الكثير من
المحللين ترامب يحاول استغلال هذا الموضوع
لصالحه بالمناسبه من اجل حجد مؤيديه من
الجمهوريين وايضا من اجل جمع الاموال
لحملتها الانتخابيه حتى انه بعد الصحف
تقول بانه سيكون سعيد اذا تم تكبير يديها
امام الصحافه ولكن هذا امر قد لا يحدث
لانه كما نعرفه كان رئيسا سابقا وهناك
احترام لهذا
الخصوص يعني كان هناك ربما بالون اختبار
لهذه المساله بالصوره المفبركه التي تم
نشرها باستخدام تقنيه الديب فيك عندما جرت
سره وهو معتقل كيف كانت ردود الفعل حول
هذه المساله ايضا هل فعلا هي تخدمه
انتخابيا حسين
هذا ما يحذر منه الكثيرون لسيمه من
الديمقراطيين يحذرون من ان دونالد ترامب
سيحاول فعل المستحيل من اجل استغلال كل
نقطه في هذه القضيه ليصور نفسه على انه
ضحيه ويؤكد المزاعم التي يقولها بانه ضحيه
مطارده سياسيه وبانه محارب سياسيه هذه
القضيه كل هذه
التحريات او هذه التحقيقات التي تجريها
هذه الهيئه
المحققون هناك
هي مدفوعه بدوافع سياسيه وليست بدوافع
قانونيه وقضائيه هناك تحذيرات من انه
سيستفيد منها وهو يعمل على ذلك ولهذا
السبب لربما كما تفضلت هذه الصور التي
نشرت انتشرت كناري في الهشيم عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كلها يرى المراقبون
بانها تفيد ترامب اكثر مما تضره ولسيمه من
الديمقراطيين الذين يحضرون من هذا الموضوع
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مباشره من امام محكمه
الجنايات في منها
[موسيقى]
قالت بربين بولدن الرئيسه المشاركه لحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطيه التركيه ان الحزب
المؤيد للاكراد وحلفائه لايري يدافع او لا
يدفعوا بمرشحين في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقرر لاجراءها في مايو المقبل وفي
تصريحاتها لم تذكر بولدن ان كانت تحالف
سيدعم المرشح المعارضه كما الكليج داروغلو
بعد اجتماع في مطلع الاسبوع ويعد حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي هو ثالث اكبر حزب في
البرلمان التركي ويحظى بنسبه تاييد تتجاوز
العشره في المئه على مستوى تركيا
في خطوه متوقعه اعلنت تحالف العمل والحريه
المعارض في تركيا عدم طرح اي مرشح رئاسي
في الانتخابات القادمه ما يعني دعما لمرشح
المعارضه الرئيسي كمال
اجرينا عمليه تقييم شامله لاعلان مرشح من
طرفنا في تحالف الحريه والعمل حيث كنا قد
اعلنا سابقا اننا سنسمي مرشحا لرئاسه بعد
تقييم الشامل نعلن رسميا باننا لن نقدم
مرشحا باسم التحالف لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه وسنتحمل مسؤوليتنا
التاريخيه في مواجهه نظام حكم الرجل
الواحد القائم حاليا
التحالف الذي يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد اتخذ هذا القرار بعد
اجتماع قياده الحزب الكردي مع كل جدار
اوغلو الاثنين الماضي حيث يسعى زعيم
المعارضه لكسب دعم ناخبين الاكراد كممثل
عن تحالف الامه المعارض او ما بات يعرف
باسم الطاوله السداسيه هذا التحالف تقدم
بدوره رسميا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
بطلب
ترشيحكين مله اتفاقنا
جئنا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات مع
الاعضاء المعقرين في تحالف الامه قدمنا
طلبه ترشيح الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه كماركل شدار اوغلو
في المعسكر المقابل تبدو مهمه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان صعبه في الانتخابات القادمه
في ظل دعم جديد تلقاه كالجدار اوكلو وايضا
ما ذكره نائب رئيس الوزراء السابق محمد
شمشك عن رفضه الانخراط في اي منصب حكومي
مع حكومه اردوغان القادمه في حال فاز
الرئيس بالانتخابات
قال انه لن يستمر في العمل السياسي ليس له
تاثير محتمل في الانتخابات برايي من جانب
المعارضه خصوصا يوجد استقطاب كبير وهم
يرون انه الوقت الانسب لرحيل اردوغان
في ضوء المستجدات الراهنه يحاول تحالف
الشعب الذي يقوده اردوغان تعزيز تحالفه
وكسب فئات جديده لذلك تحالف مع حزب الدعوه
الحره المدعوم من الاكراد المحافظين لا شك
ان هذه الانتخابات تمثل مساله حياه او موت
للقطبين الرئيسيين فيها وهما اردوغان
وكليجدار اوغلو لذلك من المنتظر ان نشهد
في الايام القادمه مزيدا من التحركات تجاه
تيارات سياسيه كانت على الهامش يوما ما
بغيت جذب اصواتها لاحد المرشحين زيدان
زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
شدد رئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك شوتشي تشو على
ان التطبيق لم ولن يشارك بيانات
المستخدمين الامريكيين مع الحكومه الصينيه
واكد ان شركه الام لتيك توك باي دانس ليست
مملوكه لاي كيان حكومي ولن تولي اهتماما
لطلب مماثل في حال تم تقدم به وينتظر ان
يدلي الرئيس التنفيذي بشهادته امام لجنه
الطاقه والتجاره في مجلس النواب الامريكي
وبشان تيك توك تتسابق واشنطن وبكين
للسيطره على الخوارزميات التي تشغل
التطبيق واشنطن طلبت من مالكي تيك توك في
الصين بيعه اسهمهم او مواجهه خطر حظر
التطبيق الصين بدورها تحاول التهرب من
عمليه البيع عبر سن تشريعات تمنع ربما
تؤخر ما تسعى اليه الولايات المتحده الى
جانب عوائق اخرى تقف امام هذه الخطوه حيث
ان 60% من اسهم بايت دانس الشركه الامه
لتطبيق تيك توك مملوكه للمستثمرين عالميين
في حين ان عشرين بالمئه مملوكه للموظفين
وعشرين بالمئه اخرى لمؤسسها
وعلى الرغم من عدم حاجتها الى المزيد من
راس المال جمعت باي دانس نحو خمسه مليار
دولار بتقييم قدره 180 مليار دولار لتوسيع
قاعدتها من المساهمين الامريكيين خطوه
تاتي في وقت يتوقع ان يزيد عدد مستخدمي
التطبيق بسبب الحظر الامريكي وبعض البلدان
الاوروبيه
انا قلقه بعض الشيء لكني لم اجري بحثا
كافيا عن الموضوع على الاطلاق ربما ينبغي
فعل ذلك
انا لست قلقا بشان بيانات الشخصيه ولكن ما
يقلقني هو ان اصحاب التيك توك في الصين
اعد الخوارزميه بحيث لن ترى ما هو سلبي في
الصين بينما في الغرب سترى اشخاصا غير
جديين
انا لا املك حسابات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لانني احب الحفاظ على خصوصيتي
لماذا سوف استخدمه اذا لم يكن لدي حساب
اضع عليه معلوماتي وعلى هاتف الذي استخدمه
للدخول على وسائل التواصل
حرب عالميه يتعرض لها تطبيق تيك توك
الصينيه الذي بات يشكل تحديا كبيرا
للحكومه الامريكيه التي تسعى لتقييده
وحظره بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
مساعي الحظر قابلها تزايد شعبيه تيك توك
في الولايات المتحده رغم ان واشنطن كشفت
عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات المواقع الحكوميه
والتجسس عليها وفق صحيفه
اصبح تيك توك من اكثر تطبيقات الهواتف
الذكيه الشعبيه في البلاد لدى الملايين من
الاشخاص والشركات وفق تقرير صادر عن موقع
اكسياس الامريكي فالشركه لديها الان اكثر
من 150 مليون مستخدم في الولايات المتحده
اي ما يقرب من نصف عدد السكان في حين ان
خمسه ملايين شركه امريكيه تستخدم تطبيق
تيك توك للوصول الى عملائها ومن المتوقع
ان يحقق تطبيق اكثر من 11 مليار دولار من
عائدات الاعلانات في الولايات المتحده
بحلول عام 2024
وفي انتظار مستقبل التطبيق الذي اطلقته
الصين في عام 2016
المشرعون الذين يعارضون الحظر يطالبون
الحكومه بايجاد دليل اكثر اقناعا على ان
تيك توك يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي في حين
يقول المشرعون الذين يدعمون التحركات ضد
تيك توك ان التطبيق يمثل تهديدا لخصوصيه
بيانات المستخدم في الولايات المتحده بسبب
القوانين الصينيه التي تطلب من الشركات
مشاركه بيانات المستخدم مع الحكومه
الصينيه
معي من الرياض عبد الله السبع المحرر
التقني في اندفندا عربيه عبد الله اهلا بك
معنا هل تعتقد حقيقه ان هذا التوجه لحظر
تيك توك في الغرب هدفه هو رغبه امريكيه في
الحصول على خوارزميات تيك توك
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه لا ننسى ان من
زمان امريكا كانت مسيطره بشكل جدا كبير
على جميع منصات تواصل اجتماعيه كل
المستخدمين في العالم كانوا يستخدمون
منصات تواصل اجتماعيه امريكيه نتكلم عن
انستغرام تويتر
نتكلم عن فيسبوك يعتبر اكبر منصه اجتماعيه
حاليا وتكتب قادم بقوه للسيطره على هذه
المنصات لذلك دخول منافس واستحواذه على
حصه كبيره من السوق يعني تهديد الهيمنه
الامريكيه في منصات تواصل اجتماعيه طبعا
امريكا تتكلم حاليا عن ان تيك توك يصل الى
معلومات المستخدمين وقد يتم التلاعب
بالمستخدمين كما حصل في فتره من الزمن
وكلنا شفنا تاثير منصات تواصل اجتماعيه
على المستخدمين حول العالم لا ننكر ان
الاحداث اللي مرت في بدايه 2014 2015 كان
لمنصه التواصل اجتماعيه دور فيها لذلك خوف
امريكا من
اي منصه تواصل اجتماعيه انها ممكن تؤدي
الى مشاكل داخل الولايات ولكن هل حقيقه
عبد الله هل خوارزميات تيك توك تفوقت على
خوارزميات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الغربيه وبالتالي هناك رغبه امريكيه في
الحصول عليها
هذا شيء طبيعي جدا تيك توك يعتبر واحد من
اذكى منصات تواصل اجتماعيه التي تعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي لذلك قاعد تطلع محتوى
جدا مناسب للمستخدمين حسب المحتوى اللي
انت تبغاه يطلع لك المحتوى بشكل كامل وهذا
ساهم ان المستخدمين يقضون وقت طويل جدا
وللاسف سبب ادمان عند المستخدمين اكثر من
بقيه منصات تواصل اجتماعيه لكن كل منصات
التواصل الاجتماعيه حاليا قاعد تقلد
الخوارزميات الخاصه بتيكتوك استعدادا
لحجبه داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وانا ما اشوف الموضوع هذا مستبعد بشكل جدا
كبير من حجم ولكن عبد الله كما يقال طبعا
كل ممنوع مرغوب بدايه الحديث عن الحظر
ورغم الحديث عن المخاطر عن اختراق
الخصوصيه
والحصول على بيانات المستخدمين من قبل
الصين الا ان الملاحظ انه شعبيه تيك توك
ازدادت بعد هذا في الغرب الى اين هل تعتقد
ان الحظر يمكن ان يزيد في عدد مستخدمي تيك
توك اكثر
لا مجرد ضيق على احد التطبيقات راح يتم
استبعادها وانتقاله الى تطبيقات ثانيه
خاصه انستجرام حاليا قريب جدا للوصول الى
نفس جوده تيك توك تيك توك اخذ سنوات طويله
حتى يوصل الى جوده جدا مميزه في عرض
المحتوى انستجرام حاليا قاعد يوصل الى
جوده مناسبه جدا تفوق على يوتيوب تفوق على
سناب شات اللي قاعد تحاول تقلد منصه تيك
توك لكن اتوقع اتوقع اتوقع ان تيك توك قد
يكون له نصيب من الحجب في امريكا في حال
ما تم بيع التطبيق الى مستثمرين امريكان
وهي وسيله ضغط عليهم اتوقع انه الفيسبوك
راح تكون اكبر رابح ويوتيوب راح يكونون
اكبر رابحين من حجب تيك توك وهو امر جدا
راح يكون متوقع خاصه ان الشركات كانت تصنع
بشكل جدا عالي في تيك توك وتصرف جدا عالي
في انستجرام ويوتيوب وتويتر على الاعلانات
فلذلك
ذهاب حصه كبير من الاعلانات الى منصه خارج
امريكا يعني التاثير على شبكات المنصات
التواصل الاجتماعيه لامريكا لذلك تيك توك
اما ان يتم حجبه او يتم بيعه الى منصات
امريكيه مع العلم ترى محجوب في دول مختلفه
واتوقع امريكا قاعد تسوي نفس الحركه اللي
قاعد تسويها الصين الصين حاليا ولا منصه
اجتماعيه موجوده في الاراضي الصينيه فذلك
امريكا قاعد تسوي نفس الضغط على الصين ولا
تسمحين لمنصاتنا التواصل الاجتماعيه تكون
موجوده في الصين من اعلانات او انه راح
نحجب تيك توك في امريكا وام
ر وارد في حجم المنصه عبد الله سبع انت
المحرر التقني في العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
من الرياض
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في سبع ولايات
المانيا تطارد عناصر خليه الرايخ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه قرر
الاحتياطيه الفيدراليه الامريكيه رفع سعر
الفائده الرئيسي بمقدار 25 نقطه اساس الى
نطاق يتراوح بين 4.75 بالمئه وخمسه بالمئه
واشار الفيدرالي الى انه على وشك التوقف
مؤقتا عن رفع اسعار الفائده في الظل
لاضطرابات الاخيره في الاسواق الماليه
والتي حفزتها او حفزها انهيار بنوك
امريكيه وقال المجلس ان التضخم لا يزال
مرتفعا لكن النظام المصرفي سليم ومرن
وبعد قرار الفيدرالي هذا اكد رئيس
الاحتياطي جيرمباول في المؤتمر الصحفي على
توجيهات البنك بخفض معدلات التضخم الى
المستهدفات السابقه عند اثنين في المئه
ان معدلات التضخم ما زالت مرتفعه كثيرا
وسوق العمل ما زالت قويه اتفاهم وزملائي
اثار التضخم السيئه على الاقتصاد واريد ان
اؤكد اننا ملتزمون وبشده بخفض معدلات
التضخم الى مستهدفاتنا عند اثنين في المئه
ضمان استقرار الاسعار هو مسؤوليه
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي وبدون استقرار
الاسعار فان الاقتصاد لن يكون جيدا لاي
احد اذا بعد قرار الفتره الامريكي نلقي
نظره الان على الاسواق الامريكيه التي
تصطبق باللون الاحمر كما نتابع نزولا الان
كذلك نظره على العملات الرئيسيه مقابل
الدولار
نعم والى اسهم البنوك الامريكيه ايضا كلها
الى انخفاض طفيف ما بين النقطه الى ثلاث
نقاط نزولا اذا هذه اسهم البنوك الامريكيه
وبعد رفع الاحتياطي الفيدرالي اسعار
الفائده اذا بربع نقطه مئويه قرره البنك
المركزي السعودي ساما رفع معدلات اعاده
الشراء ومعدلات اعاده شراء العكسيه بخمسه
وعشرين نقطه اساس كما رفع البنك المركزي
القطري اسعار الفائده على الايداع
والاقراب بخمسه وعشرين نقطه اساس كما قرر
البنك المركزي البحريني رفع اسعار الفائده
بربع نقطه مئويه ايضا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت السلطات الالمانيه تنفيذ مداهمات
على صله بحركه الرايخ التي تنتمي لاقصى
اليمين وقالت وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه ان
هذه المداهمات تتعلق بتحقيقات في قضيه
خليه الرايخ وذلك في سبع ولايات المانيه
واشارت مراسله العربيه الى ان حمله
المداهمات هذه استهدفت خمسه من المشتبه
بهم الشرطيه من القوات الخاصه اصيب بطلق
النبي من عنصر بالخليج
نفى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق بورس
جونسون تضليل البرلمان البريطاني فيما يخص
فضيحه الحفلات لكنه عبر في الوقت نفسه عن
اسفه على انتهاك قواعد الاغلاق خلال فتره
كورونا
ما هذا خطا وانا اسف عليه بمراره اتفهم
الغضب العام وما زلت اعتذر عما حدث واتحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله ولكن كما قلت للتو فان
الغرض من هذا التحقيق ليس اعاده فتح ما
يسمى ببوابه الحزب بل الاكتشاف ما اذا كنت
قد كذبت على البرلمان ام لا وقمت بتضليل
زملائي عن عمد حول ما كنت اعرفه وامنت به
بشان تلك التجمعات عندما قلت ان القواعد
والارشادات قد تم اتباعها انا هنا لاقول
انني لم اكذب على الاطلاق
كما اخبرتكم هل تعتقدون ان هذا القانون
يعجبني قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد لا
يعجبني شخصيا ولكنه من اجل المصلحه العامه
واود الاشاره الى انه يجب ان يدخل قانون
التقاعد حيز التنفيذ بحلول نهايه هذا
العام وقانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد ضروري
لانقاذ النظام باكمله في الوقت ذاته لا
يمكن قبول التمرد في الشارع ضد قانون
التقاعد وسنعمل على العوده الى الحياه
الطبيعيه في فرنسا باسرع وقت
القانون كانت له تابعه سلبيه على شعبيه
ماكرون لكن الاخير لا يابه يعلم ذلك هو
مستعد له باصراره على القانون هو بنفسه
قال ذلك
اقول لكم بمسؤوليه انا لا اتطلع الى اعاده
انتخابي لا يمكنني دستوريا لكن بين
استطلاعات الراي والمدى القصير والمصلحه
العامه للبلاد اختار المصلحه العامه
للبلاد واذا كان من الضروري تحمل ان اخسر
الشعبيه اليوم فسوف اتحملها
معي من فريز مراسلنا فادي دهوك فادي اهلا
بك هل سيكون الخميس اسودا في فرنسا
اهلا صهيب الخميس سيكون اسود لكن ايضا هذه
الليله يمكن ان تكون سوداء هنا كما ترون
عدد كبير من قوات الشرطه يبحثون عن
متظاهرين هناك تظاهرات تخرج الان في عدد
من الشوارع ايضا نحن نبحث عن هذه
التظاهرات قبل قليل كنا في موقع فيه تظاهر
لكن تمكنت الشرطه من تطويق المتظاهرين
وكما قلت سابقا في احدى النشرات بسياسه
فرق تسد تمكنوا من تفريقهم واخراجهم من
المنطقه صهيب لكن التظاهرات مستمره يوم غد
سيكون يوم الاضراب والتظاهر الكبير هناك
حشد امني كبير جدا تحضر له السلطات نحو 12
الف شرطي سيكون منتشر في شوارع فرنسا
وايضا سيكون هناك تاهب ابني من قبل القوات
الخاصه التي هي تقوم بقمع اعمال العنف
وهؤلاء هم يستخدمون الدراجات الناريه كما
ترون هذه احدى الكتاب التي تتدخل بعنف
شديد ضد المتظاهرين عدد المتظاهرين بلغ
حتى الان
معتقلا منذ منذ يوم الخميس الماضي بحسب ما
اعلن وزير الداخليه جيرالدرنا يوم امس نعم
يعني نتابع معك بدايه استعداد السلطات
الفرنسيه لهذا الخميس الاسود كما يسميه
المحتاجون طيب فادي كلام الرئيس ماكرون
واقراره بانه قانون رفعت سن التقاعد في
فرنسا من 62 الى 64 عام لا يعجبه شخصيا
ولكن هذا لمصلحه الفرنسيين كيف كانت ردات
الفعل كيف تجاوب الفرنسيون او كان صدى هذه
التصريحات من رئيسهم عليهم
الفعل السياسيه كانت عنيفه جدا هناك كانت
انتقادات كبيره من كل القوى حقيقه التي
تعارض هذا القانون خصوصا من اقصى اليمين
واقصى اليسار لكن في الشارع قبل قليل في
احدى التظاهرات التي كنا متواجدين فيها
كانت الهتافات ضد ماكرون كانوا يهدفون
ماكرون مقزز كانوا يهدفون لوبين مقززه
وايضا كل الطبقه السياسيه كانوا يهدفون كل
ضد كل سياسيين الفرنسيين وهؤلاء هم مجموعه
من الطلاب الذين يتظاهرون ويسيطرون على
الشارع منذ يوم الخميس الماضي يقومون
باحراق الشوارع والقمامه المنتشره في
الشوارع لكي يعرقلوا تحرك قوات الشرطه
التي تبحث عنهم في كل حاره وفي كل شارع
كما ترون هذه مجموعه جديده الان من كتائب
قوات القمع التي وصلت الى هذه المنطقه لان
هناك كان عدد من المتظاهرين الذين هدفوا
قليلا ثم انسحبوا من هذه المنطقه بعد ما
جاءت هذه القوات التابعه للشرطه الفرنسيه
مباشره من باريس
فتحت الحدائق وفي العاصمه اليابانيه طوكيو
وتحديدا في مدينتي كيوتو واوساكا ابوابها
امام السكان والسائحين لرؤيه مهرجان ازهار
الكرز الشهير المهرجان هو تقليد ياباني
للاحتفال بحلول موسم الربيع حيث اعلنت
وكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه قبل اسبوع
ان ازهار الاشجار بدات في التفتح في طوكيو
وذلك قبل عشره ايام من الموعد المعتاد
وقبل سته ايام من العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
بسبب المقالات المتداوله التي تفيد بانه
لم يحن وقت موسم ورده الساكورا كنا خائفين
من اننا لن نراها لكن بعد رؤيتها شعرنا
بالسعاده والفرح
بالنسبه لي كانت رائعه انتظرنا وقتا طويلا
لم نكن نعرف ما نتوقعه وبالتاكيد كانت
رحله مختلفه لا مثيل لها
انها جميله ومميزه للغايه ليس لدينا هذا
النوع من الاشجار في الدنمارك والجو بارد
جدا وغائم هناك
[موسيقى]
الساعه انتهت وهذه ابرز اخبارها
يورانيوم مستنفذ بكياب واخر حقيقي الى
بيلاروسيا يقربان خطوات من الحرب النوويه
مساعي الولايات المتحده لحظر تيك توك
تقابل بزياده شعبيه التطبيق واشنطن وفيكين
تتنافسان على الخوارزميات
المحتجون في فرنسا يستبقون الخميس الاسود
بالتظاهر
يتحداهم ويصر على قانون التقاعد
بعد اسبوعين داميين في القطاع المصرفي
الفيدرالي الامريكيه يرفع الفائده بمعدل
ربع نقطه مئويه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه على صفحاتنا على مواقع
التواصل رمضان كريم وكل عام وانتم بالف
خير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]